en yvelines comme dans l'île de france
en général
la crise ne s'arrange pas et plus en
plus de monde
même si le nombre de décès ne manquent
pas dans les yvelines à ma connaissance
le nombre de personnes qui sont
fiévreuse qui ont eu symptômes qui sont
hospitalisés lui augmente donc c'est une
des cause de préoccupations qui s'ajoute
à l'observation de comportements
irresponsables qui risque d'ajouter
encore des difficultés on va dire qu'il
ya plusieurs centaines de gendarmes et
de policiers
et j'ajoute de policiers municipaux à
l'oeuvre dans le département des
yvelines
s'il ya des contrôles c'est pour montrer
que la chose sérieuse
ça ne nous fait pas spécialement plaisir
de constater qu'il ya une nécessité de
rappeler à la population
l'absolu besoin de se confiner
nous avons dû fait qu'il ya du monde sur
le terrain comme je les dis procédé à
des centaines de contrôles et déjà 284
verbalisation
[Musique]
je réponds que c'est une vraie question
nous en avons parlé entre préfet ce
matin je sais que le gouvernement va
s'en saisir parce que c'est une question
qui paraît légitime
en tout cas sur le plan des masques
c'est une de mes préoccupations majeures
en ce moment nous faisons tout pour
recenser les stocks qui existent les
mettre à disposition de la zone de
défense pour d'abord les soignants les
médecins les aides soignant les malades
bien entendu et puis on verra quelle
sera la doctrine d'utilisation des
masques pas pour les forces de sécurité